-You look fantastic.
Hello and thank you
for coming on the show.
-Thanks.
-This is your first time
on the show,
but this is not the first time
I've interviewed you.
-Very true.
-Do you remember this?
-I do. I actually mentioned it
to your producer.
I had no idea.
I was like,
"I've been on the show.
She's like, "No, you haven't."
-Yeah.
This is the truth.
It was 19 years ago.
I found this out.
I guest-hosted for
David Letterman.
I remember I did it.
And you did me such a favor,
because we were friends.
And they were like, "Who --
do you have any famous friend
that want to come on the show?"
They couldn't book the show
because I was the host,
and no one really knew me.
So I said,
"Chloë, please help me out."
And Rufus Wainwright --
he helped me out, as well.
But you came on
and talked with me.
And I have a photo.
This is us 19 years ago on
"David Letterman."
-Cute!
-Look at us.
Buddy...
Look at us.
-Look, I'm wearing
the same dress.
-You're wearing the same dress.
I mean, look at this.
We could -- Let's re-create it.
I'm trying to
re-create it right now.
Let's do it. Yeah.
Oh, yeah, perfect.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Anyways, I'll never forget that.
Thank you for doing that.
-Anytime.
-I mean, we have so much
to talk about.
Congratulations.
You got married.
I'm very --
[ Cheers and applause ]
You actually -- This is your --
Actually, you got married twice.
-Twice to the same man.
-To the same man. Yeah.
We'll have to get into this,
because this is the first one.
This is your picture here.
This is City Hall.
Congratulations.
-Yes.
-I'm you know, disguising,
with the black dress,
a very large baby bump.
So, yes --
yes, a shotgun wedding.
-Yeah, so you had a
shotgun wedding.
This is March 2020.
-Yes.
We did not want to have the
baby out of wedlock.
-Yeah. There you go.
So, you did that.
How was City Hall?
-Also, there was
a green-card issue.
And love, of course, yeah.
-Of course love.
Start with love.
Love first, then green card.
Yeah, not in that order.
Yeah. Of course. Yes.
But then,
when was your second wedding?
-Sunday, a few days ago.
-Oh, my gosh!
Hey, congratulations.
-I know.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey!
Look at this. Beautiful.
Look at the gorgeous couple
right there.
Oh, my gosh.
-Yes. 13 years younger.
-I mean -- Ooh, hey.
Watch out. Watch out.
-I'm doing that right.
-Yeah. I'm so happy for you.
I want to talk about
"Girl from Plainville,"
but I also want to talk about
"Russian Doll,"
because I think when I was
friends with you back then,
we were hanging out with
Natasha Lyonne.
-Yeah, Rufus lived with Natasha.
-That's right!
-Yes, yes.
And wrote a song for Natasha.
-Yes.
-That's right.
-Yeah.
♪ Oh, Natasha ♪
-Oh, it's beautiful.
But Natasha is now hosting
"Saturday Night Live."
-I know. I'll be back here
tomorrow to see her.
I'm going to be in the audience.
First time in
the audience at "SNL."
-You have to.
But in this series -- I don't
know if I can say any spoilers.
But you play her mother?
-I play her mother.
-How is that possible?
-And then she does some
time traveling.
-Okay, gotcha.
Okay, that makes sense.
-Well, I'm her mother
in flashbacks,
and then she does
some time traveling
and she inhabits my body.
So then I had to do, like,
Natasha's Nadia shtick,
which was very difficult for me.
-You do that and then you go
into "The Girl from Plainville,"
which by the way, oh, my gosh.
You're fantastic in this show.
Congrats.
You're getting rave reviews.
It is -- It is a real --
It's a heartbreaking story.
-It's challenging, yes.
-A true story.
-It's a true story.
Yeah, it's based on this
unprecedented
texting suicide case.
And I play Lynn Roy, the mother
of the boy who took his life.
But it was very important to her
that people hear
her son's story, and she was
really behind the project.
So, you know -- Yeah.
-Yeah, I'm glad you did it.
And you're just so good in it.
And I want to show
everyone a clip.
Here's Chloe Sevigny and
Elle Fanning in
"The Girl from Plainville."
Take a look.
-I miss him.
-Me too.
He left you a note, sweetheart.
-Oh. He did?
Well, can I read it?
-Well, I didn't bring it here.
I didn't think it
was appropriate.
-No, no, yeah. Of course.
-Oh, that's how you do it
right there.
That is how you do it.
Chloë Sevigny, everybody.
"The Girl from Plainville" is
streaming now on Hulu.
Come back whenever you want.
-I love to.
-I love you, bud.